there was occasional firing at the
trimester because crowds tried to reach
uh the airport
a couple of times the warnings of
attacks everybody landed by the armor
and helmets and take cover
they spent almost five years as our
bureau chief in kabul
[Music]
[Music]
the italian embassy had arranged a
repatriation flight
and the initial idea was that there
would be a meeting at the airport gate
where they would direct you in and then
go there but the airport was already
surrounded by thousand thousand people
and the road to the airport was no
longer possible
so they had to fly everyone they could
by helicopter from the american embassy
compound which is next door to the
italian one
[Music]
there was no food i was just on my phone
writing and luckily i managed to find a
uh
an outlet for power to charge up my
phone
later in the day and when crowds got
even bigger and rowdier and and the us
marines started to shoot here
us marine for quick reaction force was
called in to deal with the situation of
you know hundreds of afghan civilians
uh trying to board an idling c-17 plane
that was on the tarmac the plane
actually took off with about 600 people
in there pac-like sardines
the military airport doesn't have any
normal facilities you don't have these
sort of boarding vehicles or the ramps
so uh there is the submerged ladder that
comes with the aircraft itself and uh
you have to climb up which is uh for
people
that had strollers for babies was quite
difficult
[Music]
we were waiting
uh because a lot of the afghan staff a
lot of the other italians
were not able to make it to the airport
they were straining it outside they were
starting the city the checkpoints were
closed
and then a lot of people didn't make